G: I have the personality that babies don't like, usually.
G: = Grace, Glo: = Glozell
G: Hi, my name is Grace Helbig, if you do not know, now you know. Your life is different now. Look who's here!
Glo: Hello this is Glozell. Is you okay? Is you good? Cause I want to know! Was I supposed to say that softer like you or... G: No, you're great.
Glo: Okay! G: Okay, so we just, over on Glozell's channel, made some really
festive holiday sweaters. When you're done make sure you go watch that video because we have a future in fashion design. Glo: We need to take
it on road. G: And for my channel,
I thought that we would make festive holiday bath bombs.
Glo: Whaaaaaaaaat!? G: Have you ever made a bath bomb before? Glo: No, it sounds pretty dangerous. G: I've never made one either so this is gonna be first for both of us.
Glo: Okay? G: So we have to- Glo: We got to eat this stuff? G: No no no no no no. Glo: Acid?
Glo: Do I need gloves and something like a like a thing on my face...
...to breathe and stuff like - G: we'll find out- Glo: I mean, oh. G: Here we go!
G: It's very easy apparently. Diane got some directions for us off of Pinterest so we have all of the accoutrements...
Glo: I didn't know you was bilateral. She said *mumbles accoutrements*. G: I thought to make these extra special holiday
oriented bath bombs
We've all these little trinkets that we can put inside the bath bomb so this should be easy
Supposedly, but we'll find out. So we got to put all the dry ingredients in a bowl. So first one is...
Glo: One for you... This wet so not that. this dry. That dry. That's dry. Oh I need one of these! G: That's my gift to you. Glo: I take that.
Five dollar! What is this one of those bit-a-cons? That new money called bit-a-cons?
G: It's five euros. So when you travel to Europe you can use it. Provocative. Glo: You can just go to a exchange right? G: Uh-huh
Glo: Uh see, i don't have to go to Europe. G: Alright so first thing we need a cup of baking soda. Glo: All right, one cup.
tha-tha wina...*cough* *cough*
G: This beautiful, i'm glad we kept the fan on.
Glo: Oh, there's not gonna be none for you. G: I'll just eyeball it. Glo: Okay, there we go.
Okay now I need a half cup of citric acid. I never did acid before. You're doing acid today.
Half a cup. Where's half?
OH NONONONONO!!! I don't think you're supposed to do that. It's burnin'.
Let's see this. Citric acid is from like, from oranges. No no no no no! It's a sprouting agent.
It's a...
Uh...
*demonic noises*
So, while Glo's out, takes a break. *demonic noise* You okay?
Okay, so then we need a half cup of Epsom salt. Don't put that in your mouth. Oh, I need to put something in there though.
Yep, you need some acid. In the bowl. Don't...
In the bowl. I think I put a hole in my tooth. That jive was no joke. You look beautiful. Thank you.
We need a half cup of Epsom salt. I'm just gonna guess. That seems good.
These go in there.
Perfect! Okay now we whisk these together (ugh!) yeah, I'll just...
There you go. Snowstorm. Do you have your own cooking show?
You know what? Girl, I was thinking this... Great minds I think apart.
I mean, that's close enough. You should have a cooking show. I think you'd be perfect at it.
I want to have a cooking show called. I can't cook.
Would you come on my non cooking show? I absolutely would. But you would have to bring the food because I don't cook.
Oh, that's how it works. Oh, it's sizzlin'!
Now we put three teaspoons of olive oil.
And then I put in essential oil in it. You want this one? This one is the good night one.
What kind of essential oil called good night? That's not natural. I know her no good night tree. No good night plant. Oh my gosh
I feel air going through my teeth like I might have done something. This says you're supposed to add the wet ingredients to the dry ingredients one teaspoon at a time.
But that's not how this is going. My teeth are very cold, like I feel the air
Blowing through them. Like you know when you have a peppermint, and you slick it out, and you just have little holes
Uh huh, that's what happening. And I can't feel the top layer of my tongue.
Or my esophagus. Or anything else that's in there. Alright, so now,
what do I do? Now you mix it and you can put colors in it if you want.
I'm gonna use hmm, green maybe? And then you mix it and you put them in these little molds
But then we're gonna make them holiday themed I putting gifts inside them for people!
Here, I'm mixing mine and then put a little elf inside. Do I have everything in mine, for real, like i'm like for real like...
and maybe more olive oil
that you can put in your mouth, but that
mm-hmm *gargling*
Okay, then you pack them... *choking noise*
Did you swallow all that? Oh my god...
Well, I just want you to know that my teeth are on fire!
You have a beautiful voice. My teeth is on! But what...
Is this good? That looks great. How bout this, I put a bath bomb inside of a bath bomb. I'll put santa in. That sounds great.
So it just fix or we gonna freeze them. No they just dry. We can sell on ecy or esy.
It sound like one of my auntie's name. Emma, Erma, Etsa, Etiby?
Oh my gosh it burns, don't do that. Don't put it in your mouth.
You should have a series called "Can this go in my mouth or not?"
Oh, so this is why you get paid the big bucks because it's like your mind be going all the time.
I just like regular earth person and you just be honey woah. Goodness gracious... GRACE-CIOUS!
Channelled it.
So now what, am I done? So you're done.
Now you just let it dry. You let it dry for...
...I don't know how long. It dries pretty quickly and then you can take the molds off, and then you have a bath bomb.
But if I don't use these rings can i still have them? Yes you can.
I'm gonna see if this first one I did dried already. Mmm. It's a little sticky still. Oh my gosh it looks good though!
And you would never know there's a treasure inside!
And this wasn't that hard to make but I do want to tell you that for some reason my mouth is on fire
Don't put in your mouth
I think that's the major takeaway here if you're making bath bombs for the holidays is don't put the ingredients in your mouth
It sizzles and burns, and I think that a tooth has melted. *amazement sounds*
Oh my gosh, it looks like a little ornament though! Yeah, but it might fall apart.
That's okay. And then Diane bought this that you can... But if you drop it it's just gone...
This is also a learning process that you don't have to follow the directions to get a successful product.
I'm so proud of you right now. Thank you. Can I open yours and see if it's dried?
Um, i'm a little concerned. I have complete faith.
Ooo, it kind of worked! Look how pretty that is! It is pretty!
That looks gorgeous! It's like operation. Oh! So beautiful. There we go. Oh.
You have a treasure trove
Yes, but you said I can have it. You can have it. Okay.
And you can have a great time watching the video we did over on Glozell's channel.
Yes, please subscribe, click like to miss Grace and all her channels, all her Instagram, snapchat
I don't know though, is there anybody on pinterest? The ghost on vine. Everybody you know make sure you scribe to her cause
She really cool, and um, i get to keep this? You can keep whatever you would like.
Make sure you go check out Glozell's channel and follow her across all social media because she's up to shenanigans.
You are amazing. I can't believe this. We made 'em!
I mean you, I have a feeling could probably do a better job at home, so good luck to you, and thank you Glozell for um
Just a real fun time. I want to say like this is like I'm Snoop Dogg and you're like, Martha Stewart
I just want to put that out there because... I think that's a fair assessment...This was a beautiful moment
I Don't know
I've never experienced this with a baby ever. Children don't like me, at all. Really? That's what i thought.
Are you comfortable? Okay.